you know it's so funny because uh during
i've not had a haircut as you can tell
or as many people can tell
during uh during the pandemic
and so for the first time in years my
hair's been getting in my eyes
so a couple of months ago i started
wearing uh not on the air but just
around
when we're doing the shows and we're
taping them my assistant who's always
socially distant but i'll be talking to
her
and i'll be wearing this thing to keep
the hair out of my eyes and one day
she was like you look like somebody you
remind me of somebody and i'm like
who and then she said you look like
johnny lawrence and i realized
because i'm usually scowling at her
right so you have the bad ass kind of
i've got the badass i mean i'm not as
you know good looking as this guy but
i had that kind of you know sort of
blondish
guy with my hair up and i'd be telling
her things like you can't handle it sona
come on give me my coffee and should say
oh my god
you're cooking well enough alone
that's what you should have to say once
you vote i often dress up in a skeleton
costume
yeah i can only want her at night you
know one question i have
is that uh you seem to be in really good
shape you seem like you've taken care of
yourself
but and i'm speaking as someone who i
believe is roughly the same age you know
you've got to do some stunts now
and i and it probably started out with
you just the occasional i have to kick
coffee
an iced coffee or a boba tea in
someone's hand yeah
but um okay there's that but then they
just keep ratching it up
how are you handling that because you're
not a 17
18 year old kid anymore it hurts it all
it's all a lot of stretching
i mean you know even when the show is
pitched to me you know it was
in my view i'm saying to myself well
i'll throw a kick a punch i'll
you know demonstrate but the kids will
carry all the weight you know
and then once i got in and we did season
one and then season two and then
subsequently season three which is
coming out in 2021
every year there's more and more yeah
none of us are getting younger it takes
uh it takes a lot more work
and it takes uh it hurts
that's it this hurts and the stretching
is big and the next day you're walking
kind of silly
yeah i would um if i had to just do
just even the kick that you do the first
time your your character
uh kicks uh has to do a big kick
and it's just in that car dealership
where you have to knock uh you know a
boba tea out of someone's hand
if i did that my groin would have fallen
off yes it would have
literally detached from my body and then
we would have spent maybe
six months sewing it back in yeah
it's tough to do i mean you know billy
works hard at it he's
uh you know he's i've always he's always
been more of an athlete than i
i was even from day one but we all uh we
all have our war stories
you know it's uh
we get through it man